sieben hawking hat seine warnung vor
einem dramatischen klimawandel
wiederholt und jetzt donald trump
frontal angegriffen
er wirft tram vor der erde den
entscheidenden push stoß zu versetzen
und so für eine dramatische aufheizung
verantwortlich zu sein aber auch die
restlichen g20 staaten bekommen
schlechte noten
die umweltorganisation kleine
transparency kritisiert dass alle
führenden wirtschaftsnationen zu wenig
gegen den klimawandel tun dabei bekommt
einer der größten umweltsünder sogar
relativ gute noten welcher start assist
wick zum fixen herzlich willkommen
dorthin geht frontal auf donald trump
los war hat er nicht seine prognose von
der unbewohnbarkeit der erde in 100
jahren wiederholt die ja von zahlreichen
kolleginnen und kollegen angebracht wird
aber er befürchtet eine aufheizung der
erde auf venus niveau 250 grad
befürchtet er ab maximaltemperatur es
wäre das ende jeglichen lebens auf der
erde doppeltrap wird unserem schönen
planeten vermeidbaren ökologischen
schaden zufügen indem er die beweise für
den klima waren geleugnet und das
pariser klimaabkommen aufkündigt hat
hawking jetzt in einem vorab
veröffentlichen bbc interview gesagt er
befürchtet dass die welt in sachen klima
erwärmung vor einem dammbruch steht
sowie trammplatz politik mache könnte er
der erde den entscheidenden stoß
versetzen jump hatte ja angekündigt das
pariser klimaabkommen aufzukündigen
trotzdem haben die unterzeichnerländer
noch hoffnung dass die usa trotzdem ihr
soll erfüllen da einzelne staaten und
städte weiter den vereinbarungen des
klimaabkommens folgen wollen und
vergessen hält ausgerechnet die nasa
trump den spiegel vor und
veröffentlichte satelliten aufnahmen die
den klimawandel unzweifelhaft
dokumentieren die es zu sehen wie die
schneedecke grönlands immer dünner wird
wie das eis in der arktis zurückgeht wie
der mississippi in den usa weite teile
seines umlandes überschwemmt oder der
viertgrößte weder welt der aralsee in
zentralasien immer weiter zurückgeht
aber im vorfeld des g20-treffens in
hamburg wurde jetzt auch heftige kritik
an der klimapolitik der anderen
teilnehmerländer die umweltorganisation
kleine transparente legte eine studie
vor der nach die g20-staaten das ziel
einer erderwärmung deutlich unter zwei
grad genau so deutlich verfehlen würden
im braun turin bericht kritisieren die
autorinnen und autoren das immer noch
deutlich zu viel fossile energieträger
verbrannt werden
das tempo bei der reduktion fossile
energieträger müsse deutlich erhöht
werden
deutschland schneidet in dieser studie
besonders schlecht ab wegen der seit
2010 nahezu gleich hohen kohleverbrauch
sieht es in der bundesrepublik relativ
schlecht bei den pro kopf emissionen aus
gute noten
kommt dabei ausgerechnet einer der
größten umweltsünder china laut der
studie würde das land das ziel den
höhepunkt seiner emission 2030 zu
erreichen wahrscheinlich schon viel
früher erreichen
75 prozent der treibhaus emissionen
werden durch die g 20 länder verursacht
wenn sie so weiter machen würden würde
die erderwärmung drei bis vier grad
erreichen
die konsequenzen wären dramatisch sagt
die studie soll das zwei grad ziel
erreicht werden müssten die emissionen
schon ab 2020 sinken wie es mit den
bemühungen weiter geht darüber halten
wir euch hier natürlich auf dem
laufenden wenn ihr kein video dazu
verpassen dann drückt mir hier ein abo
aufs auge und vergesst nicht den auf die
glaube hier also hier geht es weiter mit
ausstieg aus den weltklimavertrag das
sind die folgen
einfach klicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleib dran